[Music]
the plight of the world's refugees has
come into special focus following
russia's invasion of ukraine a report
this week by the u.n refugee agency says
more than one million people have fled
to poland hungary and other nations with
as many as four million more expected to
follow if the war continues in this
country the most recent influx of
refugees came last summer following the
fall of afghanistan and one place where
they've been welcomed is the city of
clarkston georgia over four decades the
city has hosted so many refugees from so
many countries that it's become known as
the most diverse square mile in america
how difficult was it to leave
afghanistan for you
we spent our whole life in afghanistan
we had friends there our whole family
were there as 20 year old aziz walked in
his new neighborhood in suburban atlanta
he reflected on his journey there in
less than six months
your whole life has changed yeah totally
we
started from zero here now you
understand why your dad wanted to leave
though
yeah actually his life was in danger and
everyone's around him last august aziz
fled afghanistan with his parents and
siblings his dad a journalist asked to
be identified simply as ahmed and that
his identity be concealed fearing for
his family still in afghanistan he's
been named on more than one taliban hit
list
in the one list was hundred people
most of them were journalists social
activist government spokespersons and
both list the second list was of 40
people both list my name was in that
list and i was scared a lot
but it took kabul's collapse for ahmed
to leave his home he reached out to
friends from nato conferences he'd
attended over the years
u.s special forces helicoptered ahmed
his wife and kids over this chaotic
scene into the kabul airport
they were eventually flown out of the
country these brave men and women and
children from afghanistan like you see
behind us have left their entire lives
behind after several months living at
different u.s military bases the family
of six now has a home
this three-bedroom house in clarkston
georgia so in this street most of people
are
from the east asian countries myanmar
nepal india pakistan and
philippines
and also muslims from somalia other
african countries so i really like this
diversity and
knowing new people from
new countries
clarkston is known as ellis island of
the south 53 percent of the population
was born outside of the us and 60
languages are spoken in the city's one
square mile unfortunately it's not
changing it means that the more refugees
they are that means the more conflict
where they're coming from
amy zangandoo is the director of refugee
and immigrant services at inspiratus the
atlanta-based non-profit resettled
ahmed's family and thousands of others
since 1981. zangando herself is a
refugee she fled from the genocide in
rwanda in 1994. what is so special about
clarkson we have housing partners that
were willing to to be ready and work
with us the location is accessible to
public transportation we have english
classes and we have families that have
been here for a long time that has
established ethenic
restaurants and grocery stores it's a
welcoming city and it's been that way
for a very very long time
inspiratis has resettled more than 600
afghan refugees alone in the last three
months the non-profit had settled just
74 total refugees in 2020 forced to
downsize during the trump administration
which capped refugee admissions in
fiscal year 2020 at 18 000 lowest number
since congress passed the 1980 refugee
act so we're still hiring we're still
looking for resources we're still
gathering communities and partner with
us
before they want to try to bring back
it's not just the refugees in clarkston
who benefit from the town's open arms
the refugee community we're not doing it
for them they don't need us to do that
we're doing it with them how's your
coffee
georgia native kitty murray launched
refuge coffee in 2017.
the non-profit has hired and trained 50
people from over 17 countries including
her first hire leon chamdana who fled
the congo ten years ago
refugee crossing while we started even
today we are like
people from the
big family
you know i can put it like there's a few
from a big family different mother but
one father
that is refugee coffee
shambana is now a customer service
coordinator and helps run this food
pantry for the community
living in claxton
it helps us
to understand how life goes on have a
picture how life goes on in syria
without
being there it's giving you the chance
to
to have an idea how life goes on in
eritrea without bidet we are
multicultural as i said and then
different background but all of us we
are here so it gives us like the way to
see
the things
even though you are never bidets
clarkston prides itself in being about
the long welcome for residents
like shambhana who came and never left
it all starts like it has for ahmed and
his family with a place that's home
in more than just the name
has it helped here in clarkston there
are so many refugees
has that made a difference
a lot
it gets a little bit easy to adjust with
people which have same culture with you
as sometimes the same religion you know
so yeah when you're surrounded by people
from different places
who are already spend the sometimes as a
refugee so it gets a little easy
now we are starting our new life in new
country
in new culture new laws everything is
new and everything we are beginning from
the zero the people are very loving
they brought all these things
the furnitures the beds the mattress the
kitchen appliances all they're helping
us a lot and we are very thankful to
them there is a lot of afghan families
here in this area and the good thing is
the mosque is very near it is 100
meters walk my mother was always praying
for me that
you should find a house near to mosque
so you did yeah i did it now life is
getting normal a little step-by-step
and i think the thing i learned the most
is it isn't just about getting refugees
here it's then that life and helping
them to start that life aziz who we
spoke with was two semesters shy of his
college degree
can't get the transcript no from there
so he now may need to start over that's
such a huge ordeal so making little
things easier it does matter and they're
the lucky ones because there's so many
refugees or displaced persons who are
still living in camps in syria and other
parts of the world that can't get out
that's right no no country especially
during the last administration very few
were
allowed into our country right and now
their partners here have to start over
and trying to resettle yeah